we're in a very exciting place it's it's
one of almost exuberant confusion I
think that on the one hand we're
thrilled by the progress that has taken
place and that has taken place quite
frankly in a very short period of time I
mean I'm a historian so I always take
the long view of things and when you
think about the kind of progress that's
been made for LGBT people just in the
last five or ten years much less over
the course of the last 40 since
Stonewall it's astonishing the amount of
progress that's been made and again when
you compare it to the black civil rights
struggle the amount of progress that
we've made has been has been quite
accelerated in comparison to the long
black freedom struggle that dates back
to on this continent to the arrival of
the first slaves in 1619 we talk about
for centuries of a black freedom
struggle interment for decades of a
queer freedom struggle you know it puts
it in perspective and I'm constantly
trying to to use comparisons when
they're useful to make that point and so
on the one hand were thrilled and and
and there's been enormous progress on a
whole range of fronts but you know there
is still some frustration when you think
about the insidious prejudices and
discriminations that Harvey Milk and
folks were fighting against 30 years ago
and then you think about prop 8 and the
Arkansas ballot initiative which band a
single adoption and was really energized
the the movement behind the passage of
that ballot initiative was really deeply
rooted in the same kinds of prejudices
and the same kinds of discriminations
the equation of homosexuality with
pedophilia which is something that we're
still battling against that kind of
stigma that if you let us near are your
children we're going to molest them
which is absurd and so those kinds of
things endure and so I think there is a
great frustration on the other hand in
our community that progress hasn't come
further that there are still those
stigmas and those prejudices against us
and that we're still battling in the
political arena and that we're still you
know sort of 15 years after Bill Clinton
took on Don't Ask Don't Tell and sign
the Defense of Marriage Act that we're
still in many ways at Ground Zero where
we
were 15 or so years ago and so I think
there's on the one hand exhilaration
over the progress and we have to
acknowledge how much progress has been
made but in the other hand I think
there's real frustration which you've
seen in recent weeks with the president
the new president and with his Justice
Department in the brief that they put
forward defending the law the Defense of
Marriage Act law which is still on the
books
it's not going to happen overnight one
of the things that I think is happening
we should understand that no president
of the United States has ever been at
the forefront of social transformation
when you think about Abraham Lincoln
Abraham Lincoln when he came into office
was cautiously anti-slavery and he was a
colonization 'used and he was any
expressed very openly and also privately
white supremacist views he didn't think
that black folks and white folks could
live together in the same country and
get along with one another and this had
been the long view of presidents dating
back even to you know certainly
Jefferson and even in some ways
Washington and others there was a deep
belief among presidents in the 19th
century in the late 18th century that
black folks and white folks weren't
meant to get along they weren't meant to
live side by side on terms of equality
despite the nation's founding promises
and so Lincoln had to come along and
Lincoln was pushed by black folks he was
pushed by Frederick Douglass he was
pushed by Harry tub and he was pushed by
Martin Delaney to have troops fight for
the Union cause to pay them properly to
emancipate the slaves and ultimately to
come up with a new vision for the
country to change his thinking such that
black folks and white folks could live
in a biracial democracy that took him
some time same thing with Franklin
Roosevelt in the labor movement right
Franklin Roosevelt didn't come into
office thinking that unions that people
have the right to collectively bargain
and that union should be part of our
social political and economic fabric he
had to move to get to that position
Lyndon Baines Johnson or it celebrated
as the president signed the voting
rights act in the civil rights are
certainly very important to that story
in that history had to be moved i mean
fri LBJ was someone who was known to use
the n-word in closed chambers when he
was bargaining in the Senate this was a
man who was from Texas who was from
rural Texas and he had to be moved on
the issue of civil rights none of these
men ever made it to the point the end
point in their lives many cases because
they you know Lincoln obviously was shot
Roosevelt died in office and then Lyndon
Johnson stepping down because the
Vietnam conflict that all of these
presidents move from a place of one
place politically to another more
enlightened and more progressive place
but
all three of those presidents were moved
by social movements and the same is
going to be true of President Obama
President Obama is not the leader of our
social movement he may sign legislation
that will be a culmination of and a
victory for our movement but Barack
Obama is not our leader as an LGBT
community he is an ally he needs to
become a better Ally but I have faith
based on what I saw in the campaign and
what I know of his his essential decency
and progressive principles I have faith
that his administration is going to be
the best administration for LGBT rights
that we've ever had in American history
before it's all